c'est la première fois qu'une étude de
pain canadienne se penche sur l'accès à
la réparation et les résultats sont
clairs selon un rapport d'équittaire les
Canadiens sont de moins en moins enclins
à faire réparer les produits qu'ils
achètent en tout cas quand c'est
possible problème c'est des fois ça
coûte plus cher de le réparer en 2018 le
recours à la réparation était de 22% au
Canada il est maintenant de 19%. une
baisse notable on observé c'est qu'au
Québec les gens réparent un petit peu
plus aussi donc on est vers 25% moi je
réponds tout le temps à mes affaires là
j'ai réparé mon genre tout ce qui brille
j'essaye le plus possible n'empêche
nombreux sont les obstacles à la
réparation les appareils sont moins
durables sont plus difficiles à ouvrir
on a moins accès aux outils aux pièces
aussi Tanguy marker lui a décidé de
faire un pied de nez à l'obsolescence
programmée en 2017 il a importé l'idée
du repère café à Montréal il s'agit
d'ateliers pour permettre aux gens
apprendre à réparer leurs appareils
défectueux quand ils sortent c'est
vraiment un sentiment d'euphorie de
satisfaction d'avoir réussi à réparer un
objet qui était voué à finir au vidange
malgré le succès de l'initiative
certains produits demeurent irréparables
puisque les pièces de rechange sont tout
simplement inaccessibles le commerçant
ou fabricant peut tout simplement
échapper à son obligation de fournir des
pièces de rechange simplement en visant
le consommateur lors de l'achat qu'il ne
fournit pas de service de réparation qui
ne fournit pas des pièces de rechange
Amélie côté souhaite que Québec
inscrivent le droit à la réparation dans
la loi de la protection du consommateur
afin de lui donner plus de mordant on
parle en France d'un indice de
réparabilité qui est une note sur 10 qui
est affichée sur les appareils et qui
nous permet d'avoir de l'information sur
à quel point l'objet est réparable selon
l'étude 75% des Canadiens se disent en
faveur d'une législation favorisant le
droit à la réparation ici à diacine
Radio-Canada Montréal